Hi, everyone.
I'm Yilun Du, a PhD student at
the MIT Computer Science and AI
Laboratory, or CSAIL,
and I'm researching
on how to construct
intelligent robot agents.
Today, I'll be explaining
how AI image generators work.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
First question: how do large,
text-guided diffusion models
work?
So large, text-guided
diffusion models
are trained on a very large
data set of images and captions
on the internet.
When you search up different
words on Google Search,
you can find all types
of different images
for a particular phrase.
Text image diffusion
models are trained
on millions and millions of
these image and text pairs
on the internet.
And they're trained to be able
to reconstruct and generate
images that are similar to
the images on the internet.
Because they're trained on
such massive amounts of data,
you can imagine that, when
you give this model a new text
prompt, because
it's been trained
to be able to recapture the
images that it's seen before,
it is able to generate an
image that matches the prompt.
Next question: what makes
diffusion models so impactful?
So I think the main
reason why we're
seeing all these incredible
advances with these diffusion
models is because of the fact
that we are training them
with so much data and with
so much computational power.
So the idea of
diffusion of models
themselves, it's
a very old idea.
But what really
makes them work now
is the idea that we now have
so much computational resources
and so much computational power
that we're able to train them
at very large scales.
Can you sell AI
image-generated images?
Yeah, I guess right now there
isn't really a copyright
or anything like that.
And I think people have
definitely been selling
some of these AI artworks.
I heard that
Midjourney Diffusion
was selling artwork for
millions of dollars each month.
So yeah, I think you can
definitely sell them.
I think this is a
question of like, maybe we
should add some licensing
or something like that
because these models are trained
on many, many images that
are copyrighted.
But right now, it seems like
you can easily sell them.
How are models prevented from
showing harmful or offensive
images, especially
considering the use
of open-source programs?
Yeah, this is a great question.
In practice, these
models are trained
on hundreds of millions
of images on the internet.
So there's all types of
harmful things on the internet.
In practice, one way to prevent
these models from doing this
would be to very carefully
select and curate
the images that these
models are trained on.
But currently, this
is a huge problem
with a lot of
these models, which
is why I think that a
lot of these companies
are not willing to release their
very large pre-trained models
for public use right now.
Are there potential
applications of generative AI
outside of image or text?
Can you apply it, for example,
to robotics or control?
Yeah, I think this is a
really great question.
Actually, I've been
working on some work
where we have been
directly applying
these generative models exactly
for the showcase of control.
We have this paper called
"Planning with Diffusion"
where we can use
this similar process,
this similar generative
process to represent
different trajectories
of actions.
So you can train these models on
huge amounts of robotic actions
or manipulation
demonstrations in video,
and then you can
imagine you can give
the robot a new instruction
like, "Pick up this mug."
[WHIRRING]
And then it can use the
large model, generative model
that it's trained on millions of
other videos of robots picking
up objects.
So I think there's many
different applications
for these generative models,
for example, in robotics,
or you can imagine,
for other domains,
such as protein synthesis
or molecular design.
Well, it looks like we're
out of questions now.
Thank you for
listening and asking
all these wonderful questions.
Hopefully, you learned something
about AI image generation.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]